no one knows what the world will look
like at the end of 2017 but one thing is
certain is that Star Wars the last Jedi
comes out December 15th and I for one
have ruined multiple pairs of Underpants
in anticipation I just a couple well the
intergalactic hype machine is already
fully operational and a recently
deployed Japanese template has stirred
up a jobless nest of speculation as
reported by Star Wars news the print ad
reads the most shocking truth in Star
Wars history will soon be revealed
oh you mean we're finally going to learn
whatõs gender reach in and grab my
opening comedians let's try to beat
Disney to the punch tell me all the
shocking truths we are going to learn in
the last Jedi in 60 seconds and begin
yes Tony obi-wan Kenobi's in a band
called obi-wan directions alright boys
all the droids piss and Oh
Darth Vader's full name is Darth aalam
you yes by Tim kylo Ren is boning Lena
Dunham alright boy honey the cantina
band has actually been replaced by the
Mighty Mighty Bosstones playing that one
song alright boy really going after the
boss tone tonight Tony Tim yeah han Solo
comes back to life as Harrison Ford's
character from Sabrina alright boys for
that fall F the death star plans were
actually a blueprint for friendship ah